this contest is set for one poll
with a 20-minute time limit introducing
first
being accompanied to the ring by luther
from san juan puerto rico weighing 195
pounds
sir pentako
tony we've seen these two men sir
pentaco and luther join
forces on aew dark a very unlikely duo
but
they've formed a bond and they've
actually formed a tag team known as
chaos project
yeah and it's going to be some chaos for
joey janelle have to deal with not only
sir pentago but
the very unpredictable one luther
[Music]
not even waiting for the introduction to
throwing haymakers to the face of sir
pentaco
best thing to do i think be aggressive
at the start here excalibur
and you have to remember janella is just
a few days removed from that vicious
beating
at the hands of the demo god chris
joe janella is jericho great performer
and a great star and he was just
i really think in the wrong place at the
wrong time because jericho was so
focused
and is so focused uh to get in the ring
tonight
of the pay-per-view uh at all out here
with orange cats and there you see sunny
kiss
as well yeah talk about unlikely duo
sunny kiss and joey janella
have formed a great tag team here in aew
and there we see luther
just looming over the bad boy boy
luther is a very unorthodox
unpredictable and crazy person
i i don't know how to approach him or
how to even uh talk about him because he
is so different than anyone
he is yeah in an organization filled
with uh with colorful characters
luther is perhaps the most uh most
unique yes
he's always pointing to his temple don't
know what that's about oh
sir pentaco sending janella off the top
rope onto the apron and then out to the
floor and sunny kiss getting decked on
the outside as well
i think we need to talk a lot about
serpentiko's about 18 years of
experience
in pro wrestling and at 36 years of age
his first aw match was against joey
janelle and now here they're going at it
once again
so this is a big match for him anytime
you're part of this night
be it the buy-in or the pay-per-view
itself it's a big night for you
and that's like to remind everybody that
the pay-per-view coming up at the top of
the hour you can get it from cable or
satellite pay-per-view providers
br live or fight tv internationally
here's a cover one
only a one count yeah joey's pretty
tough
joey's got a lot of resiliency and and
you know he kept coming back against
chris giarco
the other night and he he kept fighting
for all he was worth but jericho was
just in another
he was in a zone the other night on
dynamite and then jericho slamming
janelle's head into the top turnbuckle
there
that his face goes into the second
turnbuckle but luckily for janella
the pad was on there yeah i think you
see that joey still has a
a bandage on his forehead because of all
of that and he's taken a lot of
punishment
throughout his career it's nothing new
for joey chanella to take punishment
oh thunderous knee strike there by
serpentiko i think sir pentagon for his
size
really gets a lot of impact in these
blows he knows how to use his body
yeah there he covers janella kicking out
at one
serpentico bringing it back up to a
vertical position
and send them right back to the outside
and you notice those barricades turned
upward that's a very dangerous yeah it
is
those uh those feet of those barricades
facing upward as janella scent into the
other barricades
yeah those feet are like sharp edges
your right excalibur and that's very
dangerous for all
anytime you're out there with uh sharp
edges and luther you're in trouble yeah
and inside the ring serpentico was
distracting
rick knox keeping keeping his attention
diverted while luther was going to work
on janella on the floor it always amazed
me and i know you you wrestled under a
mask you still have a mask on
it amazed me how how you guys could
wrestle with the mascot it had to
it had to really uh just do something to
your being able to breathe
it's tough it's really tough your sweat
doesn't evaporate quite as effectively
there's
there's so many factors especially here
in the hot
florida sunshine wow great snap suplex
master pentaco i like sir pentagon great
form on that and now he's
he's calling for the end could be
looking for that diving foot stomp he
likes to employ
well he's got him positioned he just
what he needs to do now is get up there
quickly
don't give julia a chance to get up
janella
not moving at all as serpentico ascends
to the top rope
[Applause]
he's burning daylight tony yes he is
what happened there well he changed uh
he changed direction on us there didn't
yeah i think i think he might have
realized
that he wasted too much time instead of
coming off the top and having him cost
him
but now janella is up and that that
little stop seems to have woken
something in the bad boy
sir pentecost across the ring pillar to
post he escapes
high rising knee strike rocks janella
serpentico grabs him down by the hair
and there's the foot stomps
they could win it now he's not he needs
to get him away from the ropes here and
try to get a pin
cover one well he got out in one man
one count janella you mentioned he's
been
he's been through a lot in his career
it's going to take more than a
than a head getting slammed into the the
unexposed turnbuckle for
to keep janella down for any extended
period of time well here we go he's
going to try it again
maybe now sir pentaco heading up top
oh he went for the sent on atomico but
janella got the knees up
caught him in the back of the neck at
the upper part of the back between the
shoulder blades that time but joey's got
to finish it off now
trying something trying to continue this
offense now he's got himself an opening
here excalibur
janella seems invigorated he's got him
on the shoulder
belly driver rolls through oh the thrust
kicked in the face
and now janella sends her pentagon into
the ropes spins through flutes under
bomb
number one two no wow i thought that had
it
we had we saw three maneuvers starting
with the death valley driver
but it still didn't keep him down yeah
janella great quick combination there
just what the doctor ordered for him and
now the bad boy from asbury park headed
up
top moonsault press nobody home
serpentico goes behind rolls through oh
it's thrust kick of his own
and now low ddt he's planted janella on
the top of his head
cover one two wow what a kick out by
janella yeah that wasn't a good cover
though i mean the serpentico did not
have the uh the shoulders
pinned and that's why janelle was easily
able to kick out of it you know janelle
has had some great wins here in aw he's
beating sean spears ray phoenix kept
sabian
in singles competition and all three of
those are top-notch wrestlers
in aew let's see if he can get yet
another win it'll be his 13th win
but he needs to keep this kid
sir pentako grounded yeah that running
right hand was
uh there was nothing artful about that
tony he just he just needed to stop sir
pentecost progress and that's exactly
what he did and now both men
up on the middle rope
great contrast in styles between these
two men and cherpinsko looks like he's
in trouble
as janella has the the leg of serpentiko
hook
avalanche fisherman buster one two
no and you talk about a contrast in
styles tony
our main event tonight on all out
mjf challenging john moxley for the aew
world championship
mjf technically as sound as they come
john moxley perhaps the best brawler in
all of wrestling
great contradiction styles you're right
i look forward to it it's going to be
our main event
of a whole night of main event style
matches
watch out what does oh he got the
attention for luther
luther grabbing the ankle of the
luther with the right hand and janella
diving dropkick sends the original death
dealer to the floor
but sir pentago right be oh oh big
shot he's a great striker like i said
excalibur for a guy his size
jumping knee strike and janella comes
back clothesline takes a pentagon off
his feet
janella needs to capitalize on this
momentum
[Applause]
listen to the fans candy's name boys
joey's got that wild look about him but
i tell you the fans really draw to it
janella heading up to the high rent
district
and hits that beautiful elbow drop
bucks the far leg two three
oh whatever
joey now you can see excalibur he earned
it
because he hit uh extra pentago with a
lot of offensive moves
and finally the big elbow was the one
here it is again take a look
look at the elevation he got the landing
point was precise
that's right the point of janella's
elbow colliding dead
center of the chest on the sternum of
sir pentrick
knocks the wind out of him and secures
him to victory here
in our opening contest on the all-out
buy-in
delivering messages and more way than
one here tonight